we spent the morning as most of you know
doing a little bit of background about
how did Europe find its way to this
point where are we now and how does
Europe get out of this mess one way or
another I think the panel that you just
heard was a little bit about what
markets are thinking our markets going
to be constructive and patient and give
the politicians as long as they want or
markets going to rush their hand we're
happy
I'm personally honored F George Shultz
be on stage with us full disclosure I
met George 24 years ago when I showed up
as a freshman at Stanford and not only
by that time that he'd been Secretary of
State and Treasury and Secretary of
Labor and director of OMB but he has
been for most of us a great teacher a
great leader here at Stanford and for
folks in the u.s. who have been
operating under many of his theses many
of his policies for a long time and I
thought what we wanted to do today
George is just give give you an
opportunity to share your perspectives
on Europe both from the founding of this
experiment to the choices that they have
now so with that George thank you very
much for joining us I think in Europe as
well as throughout the world we have the
difficult fundamental problem of
governing over diversity in a world that
has changed and keeps changing fairly
rapidly I'll just mention two of the
changes that are affecting everybody
it's true throughout most of the
developed world and much of the
developing world that fertility is
falling in some cases way below the
replacement rate and longevity is rising
so populations are getting older and
largely as of say ten
fifteen years ago unanticipated so the
face of the world is changing radically
then I don't think anybody truly can
appreciate the depth of the meaning of
the information and communication
revolution it means that people
everywhere can know most anything
important fairly easily and that they
can communicate with each other and
organize it used to be that those in
charge had a semi monopoly of
information at a practical monopoly on
ability to organize that's not true
it changes the problem of governance and
particularly when you think of diversity
it makes it especially difficult
that's what is being faced around the
world and in Europe and I don't think
they are conceiving of the problem right
and therefore not handling it I don't
know what was covered in your review of
the past but let me review it for you as
I see it at the end of world war two
some gifted people mostly in the United
States but also Britain gradually in
Japan and Germany as they came back to
life and in Europe in some special ways
people looked back and what did they see
they saw two world wars the first was
settled on rather vindictive terms that
helped lead to the second one in the
Second World War
70 million people were killed civilian
and military 70 million people they saw
the Great Depression they saw the
protectionism and the competitive
valuations all of which contributed to
the depression and also to the kind of
sense of isolation that led to help lead
to the war they saw the Holocaust they
said to themselves what a crummy world
and they also said to themselves
whatever happens around the world it
affects us so we better try to design
something better that began to dawn on
people that the Soviet Union was a
heavily armed aggressive adversary and
the Cold War emerged so in that
environment there developed the concept
of containment the institution of NATO
and the World Bank and the IMF to deal
with currency and development problems
remember the World Bank originally it
was the International Bank for
Reconstruction and developed that it was
aimed at reconstructing what had been
demolished before it was poverty
oriented institution so piece by piece
gradually there developed would amounted
to an economic and security Commons
constructed that we in the United States
benefited from Europe benefited from
everybody benefited from it I was
fascinated back in the early eighties
when I'm visiting China and talking with
Dunc Xiao ping he lectured me on how
important it was to in effect he didn't
put this way maintain this Commons
because China was not ready to open it
the two openings to China within China
and to the outside world meanwhile in
Europe people are making the same
observations but in a more intimate way
in a sense how do we contain Germany and
something bigger
so that we avoid the problems of the
past so they began to look for things
that's signified Europe after all these
individual nation states were relatively
homogeneous groups you put it all
together in Europe and you have
heterogeneity but nevertheless they
wanted things that were Europe there was
originally the coal and steel community
that worked it was a positive
development they could see that as long
as they were individual countries with
trade barriers and so on they were at a
disadvantage economically and so the
Common Market emerged and that worked
because a bigger trading area led to all
kinds of economies of scale and so on
and it was a positive thing at work
then they developed the European
monetary system my friends jacquard is
staying and Helmut Schmidt had a lot to
do with it
and as I vaguely remember him it had a
tunnel that is some loosely related
currencies and then a snake in the
tunnel for harder relationships and that
worked then as the Cold War ended and
they're still trying to maintain a sense
of Europe on the security side it didn't
go very well here we had the problems in
the Balkans horrible problems in the
Balkans peter carington negotiated some
sort of a deal the Germans didn't like
it they pulled the rug out from under it
so here we had in Europe a devastating
set of events and it wasn't settled
until the United States came in and set
the Serbs back and you wound up with the
Dayton Agreement that more or less held
so they were not able to govern over
diversity in a security sense more
recently we've had Libya Britain and
France wanted to intervene the Germans
didn't but it also exhibited the fact
that defense capabilities have been
allowed to run down so much that they
ran out of ammunition it hadn't been for
the u.s. as somebody and elegantly put
it leading from behind it wouldn't have
worked meanwhile in the economic arena
they designed the euro
I can remember a meeting in Berlin and
John you were there of financiers and
economists it was I think three or four
months before the euro was introduced
and everybody was arguing against it
that this was something that couldn't
work that is if you have a bunch of
disparate economic units and you throw a
fixed exchange rate over the top of them
in the end it's not going to work that's
to be some flexibility I remember Helmut
Kohl came to the meeting and he listened
to this and then he got up and all of
his girth and he said the decision has
been made it's a matter of war and peace
it's up to you to make it work and he
left well it didn't work
hardly anything that's happened wasn't
predicted because you tried to whereas
the common market work I remember the
Agricultural Policy Helmut Schmidt came
when he was in office he's my friend and
I gathered a few of the usual suspects
around here in economics and we had a
seminar with him and everybody was
attacking the Common Agricultural Policy
and finally said I agree it's a terrible
policy but it's the only thing we have
that we can call Europe so it was this
need desire and I can understand it and
I think it is a huge achievement to have
this sense of Europe but then to make
Europe work you have to say to yourself
we're governing over diversity German
populations relative genius same with
France same with Italy they're not the
same though Italians are not like
Germans that's reality
so you have to figure out how you govern
over
versity and well you look for things
that unify people you also have to be
careful that you recognize the diversity
it's instructive to remember what Thomas
Jefferson said when he was arguing for
freedom of religion in the United States
and the separation of church and state
he said remember divided we stand so you
have to recognize that there in a
heterogenous society there are divisions
and you have to recognize them and honor
them in San Francisco 20% of the
population is ethnic Chinese and we have
Chinatown it's fine we have a Chinese
the first generation chinese-american
mayor now and he's very he's terrific
mayor and he governs over the whole city
well he's not a China mafia but San
Francisco works in this sense because
it's very diverse and it it allows the
diversity to express itself and Europe
was doing well on that score this
combinator cultural policy was at odds
with the diversity but it worked because
after all farmers were benefiting and
that goes well politically everywhere
and it wasn't that important relatives
of the big picture but the euro the
exchange rate system it is important and
now we're in the position of saying
instead of having currency cross-straits
change to accommodate changes we're
telling people that they have to take
20% cuts in pay sorry folks that doesn't
go that's politically explosive as we
can see it's not necessary there are
ways the European monetary system worked
well so
what we now see it's a kind of
scrambling rambling business with all
kinds of ideas put up and all the ideas
in the end wind up meaning the Germans
should give some money to people and
it's different ways of phrasing it and
constructing it but that's what it comes
down to and after well that runs out of
steam and the austerity prescriptions
tell people to tell their society or
their societies apart when they are
already overcommitted because of the
aging societies they've made too many
promises already which they can't keep
just as we have in the United States and
they look at California we're in a nova
shape for that reason so I think in
Europe they have to say to themselves we
are accustomed to governing over
homogeneous populations Germany Italy
France Netherlands Owen and it's
essential that we create this sense of
Europe but we have to remember that we
have to change our mindset as soon as we
say Europe
we're governing over heterogeneity so
the things that we seek to stand for
what we have in common
cannot be things at odds with the
diverse nature of our population and
when we do it on a grand scale we're
going to get in trouble and we have to
figure out how to undo it if I were in
Europe right now or advising them or
active in any way which I'm not at all
but if I were I would be saying to them
somehow we have to unwind this mistake
and if the notion of the euro is so
embedded that it's impossible to get rid
of it well then change
and kind of make it resemble the
European monetary system that Schmitt
enjoy Skaar gave you and have a soft
euro and a hard you or some way of
recognizing that there's got to be a
method for rearranging the furniture
other than causing people to do things
that are practically impossible to do
when there is at hand a tried and true
mechanism the exchange rate system has
worked well over many years and helps to
solve these problems meanwhile on the
security front I think you're a pastor
decide whether it really wants to be a
player and what stakes it has because
the bulkan exhibit and the Libyan
exhibit show that if you say there's
going to be a European Defense Force
give me a break it's not there
there's the capability isn't there the
dedication isn't there the willpower
isn't there from the United States
standpoint our stake is high but I don't
think you can Europe can continue to
expect that the United States is going
to bail them out we're having a hard
enough time bailing ourselves out so we
have to not only in Europe look at those
things but I think we in the United
States also have to work with our
friends and our friends are heavily in
Europe and how we put back together
again the economic and security Commons
which we achieved but which is for
various reasons coming apart at the
seams right now that's the task George
thank you so so allow me to ask a first
question folks that have questions for
George if they go to either of the two
microphones or to have to speak up
because of my hair you know I'm in my
90s my hair
is not as good as it used to be so what
so George I take from your discussion
today that the markets preoccupation
with what does Brussels decide about X
how is Frankfurt and Berlin decide why
what does Mario Draghi do with the ECB
that those are consequential but am i
right in hearing from you that you think
that it's the recipients of all of this
transfer who are probably none too
pleased to be feeling austerity without
any growth that there's more risk for
markets that the recipients of the good
graces of northern Europe might say this
might be working for you but it's not
working for me is that more where market
participants and policymakers should be
worried if there's a I don't think isn't
working for anybody right now that's the
problem
and you mentioned Brussels and Frankfurt
I mean here we have these nation states
they have capitals and a portion of
their sovereignty has been assigned to
Brussels trade policy which includes
immigration policy then a portion of
their sovereignty has been assigned to
Frankfurt monetary policy as I read some
of the things that are now bringing
proposed bank regulatory policy will be
assigned to Frankfurt and before long
they are talking about somehow having
some sort of a central government will
have some control over spending and
Taxation what do you have left as a
sovereign government who's responsible
where do you look you're going to make a
deal as Henry Kissinger once said tell
me the right phone number who do I call
sovereignty is dispersed and therefore
it's not as responsible as it could be
and should be I won't take a question
above all he's too smart for me you have
to give the answer as well as the
question but actually I'm only going to
give you the answer it's even see first
of all I think you're overstating the
importance of aging because there's no
better example than you of how older
people are highly productive these days
and I think that I think that the
increased productivity has more than
offset the aging effect the problem in
Europe is not a problem of the ageing of
the population it's essentially forced
retirement that ridiculous the early
ages there's a whole set of European
labor institutions that pushes people
keeps young people out of the labor
market until they're in their 30s and
then forces them out of the labor market
when they're in their 50s I mean when
you compare these the labor force
participation than in Europe of 45 year
olds is the same as it is in the US but
it's extremely much lower at young ages
and older ages so Europe needs to
harness the productive potential of its
aging population and not not treated as
harm well that's that's certainly true
but the fact that the aging population
continues to age is part of the problem
because a lot of these things were put
into effect when people thought
longevity was much less than it is so
there is a holdover problem from and a
need to reconcile the pension problems
and I completely agree with you that we
need to figure out how to organize them
so they encourage people to stay in the
labor force but we're building a
gigantic problem not only in Europe but
here in the United States because the
unemployment rates for young people are
so terribly high and it's at these early
ages when you learn your basic labor
force skills and a lot of people aren't
learning them so we're building problems
for the future by this so my second
comment is is your belief that
that a soft currency would be the answer
to the problems of southern Europe and I
you know I debated this that that seems
to be the conventional view that the
Greeks would very happily accept the
necessary 30% reduction in real wages
that Greece absolutely must go through
they'll accept it happily if they're
paid and depreciated drachmas which no
longer by nearly as many goods as they
used to buy what's the same number of
euros and I don't see any obvious basis
for that at all historically there's
been lots of examples in which large
changes in nominal wages have occurred
as necessary to get real wages in line
Tom Sargent has written very effectively
on this point where we're looking at the
world with blinders very typically when
we when we say oh well nobody will ever
accept a reduction in nominal wages
because lots of people have my father
was on the faculty of Stanford in the
1930s took a substantial reduction in
nominal wages like everybody did in the
US so I think that I think that you're
overselling everyone thinks that oh if
you're really really easy to especially
in Greece if they would just go to the
drachma and I I think that the amount of
social dislocation that would occur by
going to the drachma enforcing real
wages down would be about the same as if
they did it on the euro it would be of
course it's gonna be bad in both cases
it's a there's irreversible harm that
was caused by that maybe Bob but it
would be a Greek problem and none of
Europe problem that's the new wealth
okay but as a citizen of the world we're
saying you're saying that you've got to
get away from the notion that one size
fits all and recognize there is
diversity you don't desire deny that
Italians aren't like Germans and Greeks
aren't like Frenchmen these are
different people have different cultures
and
outlooks excuse and you have to give
room for that to express itself all the
people you're talking about use the
metric system with complete pleasure
there isn't the slightest inclination
for the Italians to have their own
measurement system just because they're
they I agree obviously too different
than the Germans but they're very happy
to cooperate on using the metric system
well I can't argue with you because
you're too good for me but but if what
you're arguing is just rock alone
everything's going great I'd say wait a
minute things aren't going great there's
a mess and it isn't getting better and
the kinds of proposals to make it to
reduce sovereignty further reduce refuse
responsibility more seemed to me to be
going in the wrong direction next
question will go to Lorenzo who recently
finished his service at the European
Central Bank and will have a tough
question I'm sure no I thought your
concepts are very interesting the two
difficult issues to to manage the speed
of information and the diversity now
diversity is not a concept which does
not change through history as you were
mentioning Chinatown I don't remember
when the Chinese got to vote in the US
but probably a hundred years ago I don't
know if they were allowed to vote
probably hundred fifty years ago the
world and many others were not I think
the u.s. went to a civil war because
people were not the same and could not
manage diversity if I think about my son
he's 13 I don't think that he feels that
different from a German kid of 13 or
even a u.s. kid
so protea diversities but from an
economic point of view in this global
world the concept of diversity is much
much lower I think so
probably we I mean of the aging part of
the society have a concept where I have
a concept of diversity which is
different from the young from the young
people so I think that's that's a
challenge for Europe I think which wants
to integrate one of the most successful
things we have in Europe for instance it
is called Erasmus people go and study
abroad because they end and they
generate this kind of generation they
feel much more European to some extent
but that was more of a comment you say
that the EMS worked well in fact it
didn't really work I was talking this
morning about how in an integrated
monetary system you have to choose an
admin the dollar was in the Bretton
Woods it's still issue some extent in
Europe he would have had to choose an
admin and the deutsche mark was the
offices so the key question was could
Europe survive in its integration
economic integration process with the
deutsche mark being the hegemon that's a
political issue I think and it's an
economic issue and many examples were
for instance meat Iran had to change its
policy because he could not stick up to
the dollar so managing together a
currency is pretty tough because it
imposes then a superstructure that
forces changes in behavior but the
alternative I would not agree with you
that the alternative is necessarily much
better and you mentioned at the
beginning of your speech the people
after world war two looking backwards
and you you quoted yourself the
competitive devaluations of the 30s
trying to beg their neighbor policy took
it out of the cry so I don't know what
would have happened in this crisis if
all the country started to devalue and
to regain competitiveness I'm not sure
it would have been a better world
in Europe so these are just a few
comments for you to react well you're
not you don't think that what I have
said would lead to a better world but
the world you've created is a downright
mess so it couldn't be worse and the EMS
came into place after the Bretton Woods
system ended them remembered ended
because well it worked for a long period
after World War two remembering that we
came out of World War two with the
United States economy the only one left
standing so we could basically sort of
stand there and in effect it wasn't a
fixed exchange rate system everybody
else devalued against us and that went
on for a long time and President Nixon
did not decide to end closed the gold
window the gold window was closed
because there were so many more dollars
out there to be redeemed at $35 an ounce
and a run was beginning so if the market
closed the gold window in effect and
that meant that you had to design a
different kind of system and I was
intimately involved in that I remember I
was director of the budget when all this
happened and I kept tax in the Treasury
people what their plan was and they told
me it was a secret
and then I became secretary of the
Treasury and I said okay what's the plan
they said we don't have one I said
that's what I thought
so I spent the summer of 1972 designing
one of course everybody wanted stability
the par value system and I thought that
you had to have some flexibility so I
had some interesting conversations with
my friend Milton Friedman and we
designed and Paul Volcker had the
laboring oar in doing this we designed a
flexible exchange rate system in the
clothing of a par value system that as
we said you set par values and they
change automatically when reserve
balances change and I remember it was
quite a struggle to get this out of the
US government and I took it over to
President Nixon he was going to give a
speech at the World Bank IMF meetings
and I said here's your speech mr.
president he looked at he said that's
not my speech that your speech so when
he addressed he said tomorrow my
secretary of the Treasury were on bail
that US approach what a hype that was
but I had done something that hadn't
been done before and I wound up paying
off very well I invited the finance
ministers of the leading countries
Germany France Britain Japan come in
individually and I showed him the speech
and asked them to come in and they all
nobody tried to mess with a basic
structure of the speech they will make
suggestions of wording and nuance that
help and I would manage to take all
their suggestions and then we formed a
little group and nobody wanted the big
countries to be telling him what to do
but we had the g20 which was totally
unmanageable so everybody wanted us to
meet and nobody wanted to know it so we
had
meeting and the president said I'm not
going to be in town so why don't you
give you a meeting a little class and
put it in the White House so we met in
the library of the White House which is
a beautiful room with a nice fireplace
and they served a good meal and so on
and we had to figure out a way to refer
to our group that didn't disclose what
it was so we decided to call it the
library group it subsequently became
reasonably famous in these circles but
result was that the finance ministers of
these countries we got to know each
other very well
became good friends still friends today
and we were able to work through this
and I remember the EMS Schmidt Nancy
scar one of our meetings took me aside
and they said what they were planning to
do to give something more European and
to give a greater sense of stability and
you said it didn't work my impression
was it worked pretty well and I remember
for example Britain got into terrible
trouble and they basically just had to
withdraw it wasn't a big deal I mean
that was a big deal for Britain but it
didn't disrupt things badly so in in a
sense it allowed for things to go wrong
and when things go wrong somewhere it
doesn't mess up everything so I thought
it went along pretty well and it was
European so it served those purposes but
I certainly agree with Bob Hall there's
a lot of reform that could be done that
would be very helpful and I think in in
this country as well as in Europe the
fact that unemployment is so high among
young people is a very ominous
development because it has huge
implications for the future question I'm
faith which really you published earlier
this year a sort of a short essay over
at C / and in it you were explaining why
the US needed to show more leadership
relative to the past and one of the
things you
was that Treasury secretary over in
Europe for meetings and the Austrian
minister said to him why should I listen
to you silly people
so with that question of years in mind
my question is if we solve the fiscal
cliff before or after Christmas and we
get just you know through first quarter
of next year here in the US what else
can we do better here to get Europe not
to listen to us but to at least consider
some of the good advice that drifts over
what should we do better to have more
authority and be more persuasive I think
the problems that we have are blindingly
obvious and the solutions are blindingly
obvious and our problem is how do we
find our way to solve them and it seems
to me and we had this problem maybe over
emphasizing my experience but I was the
chairman of Ronald Reagan's economic
advisory panel in the campaign and then
for the first year and a half of his
presidency so I watched this process and
broadly speaking what he did was to put
in place a set of policies consistent
with economic growth without inflation
and he took a beating in doing it in
other words he thought strategically
that is we all thought he agreed that we
couldn't have a decent economy with the
kind of inflation we had remember it was
in the teens and Paul Volcker was there
ready to do and doing what needed to be
done at the Fed and people keep running
into the president saying mr. president
he's doing these things you're going to
have
a recession you're gonna have
unemployment we're gonna lose seats in
the midterm election you got to do
something about it he never did he
basically held a political umbrella over
Paul I talked to Paul the other day
about it
he was my undersecretary when I was
Secretary of so I know the high quality
that he brings he said yes he remembered
that during press conferences Reagan was
served up questions by the press
constantly to criticize him and he never
did so anyway he knowingly took a
beating there was a recession we did
lose seats in the midterm election
however by the time the end of 1982
arrived early 83 inflation was under
control and the basically tax incentives
that were put in place kicked in and the
economy took off like a beard I think
the same thing can happen now basically
that is although we have built ourselves
a set of problems that are daunting
I wrote a something in The Wall Street
Journal the other day with some Hoover
Institution colleagues that tried to
point out how big the problems are that
have been created here now for us but I
believe that if we reform the personal
income sack system along the lines of
the 1986 tax act that's step 1 and
goodness that can be done it was
Reagan's proposal it worked its way
through Treasury people scored it and so
on but basically it got into the hands
of the staff of the Joint Committee on
taxation very well-respected I suppose
they still are they were then anyway by
the time we got through it was
introduced in the House by Dick Gephardt
and the Senate by Dilber
they passed the Senate 97 to 397 to 3
and Reagan was asked if it bothered and
the two Democrats introduced his
legislation you know he said it passed
and we don't have that kind of
governance anymore we've got to get back
to that kind of governance then I think
the Kirk and everybody knows the
personal income tax system needs it the
corporate income taxes too high
everybody knows that and there are these
preferences in there where GE manages
not to pay any tax so let's get rid of
those things and fix it so everybody
pays the tax whatever it is and could be
a lot lower then you have to do
something about the entitlement problems
everybody knows that it's not a mystery
that we can't go on with these wildly
escalating costs with Social Security
it's an absolute piece of cake if you
change the indexing from wage indexing
to price indexing and maybe index the
when it the age of full benefits hit 67
index it to longevity very gradual
you'll have a solvent Social Security
system it'll take a while people say it
solve until such-and-such a time
meaning that the trust fund can carry it
thanks a lot there is no trust fund the
money has been spent it's just a big
bunch of IOUs
so the general treasurer the general
Treasury is going to have to pay that
bill for a while but if you make these
reforms Social Security can be on a
self-sustaining basis and I think in the
health care area first of all I think
there's a lot of technology coming at it
if you will use it right but also you
have to get the consumer in the game and
when you react to rising costs with wage
and price control
you're going to have less of what you
control it's an absolute certainty that
you put a control on the price you're
going to get less of it so we don't want
a system that produces less health care
providers when we're expanding demand we
need to have we need to have in the
health care universal coverage let's
start with that proposition so if we
tackle these three small things maybe
Europe will begin to listen to us so
those are some things we could do
personally I think that the country
desperately needs a thoughtful
infrastructure program our
infrastructure is falling apart we
shouldn't think of it as a
counter-cyclical matter we should think
of it as a long term investment lots of
things that need to be done they should
put that into place and then my goodness
we have to get a federal reserve that
will that will be a rule space federal
reserve they have a balance sheet now I
don't know how they're gonna unbind it
frankly kevin is responsible for that
he got out before where as soon as he
could but you have created a terrible
mess Kevin and now Ben Bernanke is
saying it's a great thing for the world
that emerging economies are being forced
to intervene in their currencies to keep
them from rising so much because of the
influx of money the Fed has created
which is going to those places looking
for higher yield give me a break so
there's a lot of things that we need to
do and we can do these things that I'm
talking about and we have some pain and
agony for a while but then the economy
would take off like a bird it's there
George thank you very much George has an
engagement in San Francisco but we
really appreciate his time on Europe and
the rest of the world well I have an
engagement in San Francisco and
very important the Christopher Stevens
there's going to be a big ceremony in
his honor at City Hall and as a former
Secretary of State I want to be there
and speak but when we think of public
service and we think of the Foreign
Service and what they do this man was a
giant it's interesting that you see in
Libya the Libyans holding up signs
saying thank you Chris they understood
it it was a deliberately planned attack
probably al-qaeda oriented that killed
him but he was a fantastic person over
at Hoover we have these national
security fellows they were at the kernel
level Army Navy Air Force Marine Corps
State Department come new ones each year
and we had a meeting of them and the
army guy said he'd been stationed in
Libyan side did you know Chris Stevens
he said everybody knew Chris Stevens
he was slowed in Arabic he was
everywhere he was so constructive he was
a centerpiece and if you talk about what
it takes to rebuild a decent world this
is the kind of person it takes so it's a
tremendous tragedy that we've lost him
and my wife has organized this ceremony
in City Hall and I don't know how many
people will come but my guess is they'll
be a good turnout but we want to express
to his family that'll be there or a
grief so I'm wearing a little astark
clothing but I also wanted to express in
a sense our celebration of his
achievements it's not enough just to
grieve but also to pay our respects to
what he was able to achieve on behalf
not only of the United States but
civilized people around the world the
mission in Libya was a broadly spaced
one so that's where I'm going
so um most of you and my question said
you didn't like what I had to propose
for Europe but all you've seen proposes
more of the same and thank me more the
same isn't working if you keep doing the
same thing that doesn't work all the
time that's the definition of insanity
so come on